>> Now remember, Hart and Risley had families of a professional status,
middle-class, or welfare. And what they found was that, children from
professional families heard, on average, 2,153 words per hour. Children in the
middle-class family heard on average 1,251 words per hour. And, the children in
the welfare families heard on average 616 words per hour. Therefore, we see
that the type of family that the child was in had a great impact on the overall
number of words that they heard. But, that's not all. That means that, for
children in a professional family they had approximately 11,000,000 words per
year. those in the middle class family heard approximately 6,000,000 per year
and finally those in the welfare group heard approximately 3,000,000 words per
year. Hart and recently found that by age four, the children from the welfare
families could have heard about 30,000,000 fewer words, compared to those in
the professional family. But that's not all. Let's look at one more important
finding from Hart and Risley.